you're not changing because you're
trying to do everything yourself you're
trying to do it all alone you can have a
moment of inspiration moment of this is
the day I'm gonna change it all and then
when your environment and people around
you don't support you in doing it and
you're doing it all alone you lose
momentum the next day that momentum is
gone and the next day the momentum is is
absolutely zero have you ever you ever
been there until you get the people
around you to support you to create a
circle where you can feel like you do
not have to do this alone you won't
change and you'll stay stuck knowing
that you're capable of more and
frustrated with yourself with the lack
of momentum I run this challenge inside
my movement makers program and every
month we have to talk about a certain
topic movement makers is For Thought
leaders it's people who are they have a
message they have a mission they want to
get up to the world your story matters
let's get it out there and go come on
but it's really hard to share your story
and it's really hard to make videos and
it's really hard to put yourself out
there and you have these moments where
you want to do it and you feel on top of
the world like yes I'm ready CNN and
then what then all the insecurities and
fears and doubts creep in hey it's Nina
Carmichael and we made these videos
because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you need
a push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best my husband Evan Carmichael and
how to create meaningful change in your
life enjoy
as I was noticing people and Movie
Makers not making enough content I
decided to do a challenge and the
challenge is once a month we pick a
topic
and this month's topic is courage
and what you have to do is make a solo
video that's 10 minutes long you have to
make a lead magnet to help grow your
business and you have to do three
collaboration videos and most people do
Instagram lives to collaborate with each
other and all of a sudden
people who took up the challenge started
making content all of a sudden the
excuses went away the I don't know what
gear to buy I don't know what camera to
use I don't know what microphone I don't
know what to talk about my story is not
good enough I'll start next week I'll
start next year I'll start next month
I'll start on my birthday I'll start on
January 1st I'll start on Monday I'll
start I'll start next month right all of
the all of the excuses all of a sudden
went away
because you're not doing it alone
because all of those reasons that are
holding people back that are holding you
back you want to do something bigger
all of the reasons that are actually
holding you back are not The Logical
ones that are in your head right the
idea that you're not making content
because you don't know what phone to use
or what camera to use or what I'm sit
I'm making these videos for my channel
on my phone I'm I'm in my car at my
wife's acupuncturist she's getting
acupuncture done right now in the
building right next to me and so I'm
making content in my car you can too
right they're logical reasons why you
are not doing a thing that you want to
do right that you say is important to
you there's logical reasons that you are
buying
you've you've you believe them they are
actual reasons but they're not good
enough reasons and underneath those
reasons why you're not doing the thing
that you need to do is just that you're
afraid
it's just fear
and suffering through fear alone
is really really hard it's not that it's
not possible it's not that you can't do
it it's just immensely difficult and
most people won't most people won't
follow through most people don't follow
through because they are alone
in this journey you might have people
around you you might you might have
great parents friends a spouse but if
you feel like you're walking the journey
all by yourself
just insanely difficult to actually
follow through and get the results that
you want the good news is
you can talk the good news is you can
you can change your circle and I'm going
to share a couple ideas in this video of
how to do it so
number one
I like to collect good people
collect good people think about the
people around you in your life how many
of them make you feel happier more
energetic more positive and you may not
have many people you know there you may
not have someone like that
great
think about the people who you've ever
met
maybe it was at a conference maybe an
event maybe a lunch or dinner some kind
of party a friend of a friend
I
find ways to spend more time with good
people I remind myself that I like to
collect good people and as someone who's
shy and introverted
that's that's
not my default state
I don't think to call people I don't
think the message people I don't I don't
um default to being around people but
when there's somebody who's energy I
really love and I leave the conversation
feeling more uplifted than when I went
in
then I I try to find ways to spend more
time with that person and maybe it leads
to a business maybe it leads to some
kind of opportunity maybe just leads to
another conversation but think about the
people who you have met at some point in
your life maybe not the people around
you right now but an old high school
friend or again somebody at an event or
a club or some meeting that you met that
you really like their energy and their
Vibe I'll lean in on the awkward and say
hey do you want to go grab a coffee I'd
love to learn more about your story
or I really love your energy
do you want to go and get some lunch
together
it feels super awkward but chances are
they need somebody too
and if you be the first one to do the
Outreach and say hey I'd love to learn
more about you see the people who you
don't really know that well but you'd
like to
and you can even say that when you're
talking to them hey I don't really know
you that well but I'd like to
and lean in on the awkwardness be the
first one to go off and do it so so
think about the people in your network
people who you have met one-offs
meetings
who filled you with that positivity and
and fight for more time with them
because if you had four people
and you met everybody once a month
that's once a week now you're meeting
some amazing human
whether it's coffee whether it's lunch
whether it's a zoom call whether it's
actually forming some kind of business
together
there are people who you've come across
who
are the support that you need and you
need to do the Outreach to say hey I'd
like to get to know you a little bit
better and spend a little more time with
you
leaning on the awkwardness collect good
people that's number one two is is
change your environment to be around the
people even if you can't meet them so
watching this video is a great example
watch this video did you wake up this
morning you're like yeah my gosh so
amazing let's go crush the day
probably not right I didn't if you
if you're super jealous of you if I woke
up and you're tired and you look at your
phone and what's on my calendar for
today and immediately some of the
limiting beliefs and thoughts and
attitudes uh popped in your head and so
if you can't be around the people every
day you know the collect good people if
you can't be around them every day then
you can be around them virtually
through video through YouTube through
books through uh social media follow the
people who make you feel better about
yourself and make you want to go off and
Conquer your goals
most of the time when people are
spending time on social media YouTube
Instagram Etc
how much of that time is spent actually
learning and being inspired versus
wasting time
how many times have you opened your
phone went to a social media app and all
of a sudden 40 minutes went by you
didn't even notice because you're just
scrolling scrolling scrolling scrolling
right has that happened
that's that's that's not what you want
to do
lean in on that right
audit right now audit who you are
subscribed to on YouTube and who you're
following on Instagram and ask yourself
do these people make me feel better
about myself or not
do I leave feeling more inspired than
when I came in and if no then unfollow
those people and good news there's lots
of amazing people not just me there's
tons of amazing people who are making
amazing content
and whatever you want to learn whatever
you want to get more into
when you can surround yourself even in a
social media environment if you wanted
to work out more if you followed a whole
bunch of Fitness people people who are
working out constantly people who are
not you're making excuses for why they
can't get to the gym today if you
followed all those people it's now in
your environment you'll start to see it
more often it'll become it'll become
that daily reminder for you and you're
more likely to go to the gym and work
out so whatever you want to be whoever
you want to be whatever your goals are
choose to follow the people who are
achieving those goals who are living
that because it's not your identity yet
and for them it is and the more you're
around that they will suck you in to be
like them so choose very carefully what
you want to get sucked into right it can
also lead down a really negative dark
path right whoever is more confident in
their beliefs wins if you're around
people who are strongly believing in
something that is that is bad or evil or
you know against your core values you
know you could be sucked down a really
dark negative hole as well so Step One
is collect good people step two is to be
around them be around in social media
with intention the people who make you
feel better about yourself and and go
achieve your goals and the step three is
to join some kind of community join some
kind of group
uh who are focused in on on what you're
trying to do so if you wanna
if you want to get into fitness then you
you can hire a coach to help your
fitness trainer or join a gym or join
some kind of collective where you feel
like you don't have to do this by
yourself why movement makers is so
special is because if you want to be a
thought leader where do you go where do
you go to hang out with other thought
leaders
right nowhere do you know anybody who's
a thought leader is trying to make great
content and share and have a message to
give to the world you know who who else
that you know in your life talks like
that probably not right so being around
that and and whatever it is that you
want to learn you want to be better at
chess then join a chess club and hire a
chess coach be around the people
be around the people join some kind of
community so you don't have to do this
all alone one of the things that I
struggled the most with is feeling like
I have to come up with all the ideas
myself carrying everything on my back
and what I realized
varied later in my entrepreneurial
Journey right I mean I'm I'm
what I'm 40 how old am I now 40 I'm
almost 42 when I'm filming this video my
first Real Business and Entrepreneurship
when I was 19. so it's been a while you
know 20 plus years of being an
entrepreneur
uh not including like garage sales and
that kind of stuff and one of the
hardest things for me was just not
trying to have to do everything myself
not putting all the pressure on myself
to have to do everything everything
everything all by myself
I like to say movement makers that one
plus one equals four thousand you know
like you come in
and not just movement makers but any
anytime you do this any any club you
join or group you join especially if
you're a giver givers have a hard time
asking but when you're with other givers
they want to pour into you they want to
give to you they want to see you win as
well so you come in hoping to get
something and then when you get that
plus you can contribute to other people
and what they're doing and see that
you're showing up for them also allows
them to go off and accomplish their
goals
it's just such a great cycle
and it's such a weight lifted to know
that you don't have to do everything all
by yourself
so you could be willing to change you
could have these great Ambitions and
great ideas of who you could be and who
you want to be and the impact that you
want to have
but it's not going to happen until you
realize that you can't do this alone
stop trying to do this alone stop try to
do everything yourself
you can change people will support you
but it's on you to collect good people
to audit who you follow on social media
and to join a group of people who are
like-minded
if you want to make one single change
this year
that will have a tremendous impact on
the growth of you actually accomplishing
your goals
decide to not do this alone anymore rule
number two find your purpose
from your purpose and your purpose comes
from your pain
how do I find my purpose how do I find
my one of the number one questions
people have well it's actually pretty
easy to find your purpose you just have
to understand that it comes from your
pain whatever you struggled with the
most as a human being in your life is
the thing that you want to help other
people through
and that may be something on a big scale
where you want to change the world and
make sure that it never happens to
anybody else ever again and ease the
suffering for others along the journey
if you're watching this video you're on
this channel it's probably more the way
that you lean but it could also just be
the people closest to you
the closest members in your family that
your closest friends the the team that
you're on your co-workers those are the
people who you want to help the most you
don't have to go off and change the
world but you do have to feel like what
you do matters at the end of the day all
of us want to make sure that we wake up
and we feel like today is going to
matter
when you feel like today matters to
somebody that you can be doing work that
is unservice to other people that you
will matter to them that what you create
today will matter to them it's going to
make you feel better it's going to make
you feel alive it's going to make you
feel worthy it's going to make you feel
proud of yourself however when you wake
up and you feel like today doesn't
matter like nobody cares if you show up
that your work will be meaningless
you're just going to toil away and do
useless things we probably all had jobs
like that right if you had a job like
that you woke up you went to your work
felt like you're just gonna plug away
even if you were working hard but it
just didn't matter there's no
appreciation the work either did matter
it didn't matter if you showed up or not
but that's I think most people we've at
least had a job like that at some point
in our past and that's the path down to
feeling worthless and depression anxiety
and suicide a lot of the problems that
we're facing a lot of for for a lot of
people the biggest problem is just you
don't feel like the work you're doing is
meaning anything to anybody and and
therefore you feel like you don't matter
because because the work you're doing is
not meaning anything to other people
therefore you don't matter because deep
down we all want to serve you were built
to serve we all want to feel like what
we do matters so you don't have to
necessarily have a big vision for the
world but you do have to figure out your
purpose
and your purpose comes from your pain so
for me I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur
as a 19 year old getting this first
business off the ground and turning down
the big jobs and failing and sucking and
making no money and just pouring
everything I had into this company and
being absolutely broke
financially and and emotionally you know
the initial high of I'm going to start a
business I'm going to be an entrepreneur
we're going to do this we're going to
change the world yeah uh was great and
then it wears off when you realize
nothing is happening we're barely
getting any customers we're barely
making any money the the the the high of
the launch Fades pretty quickly and then
you're in the muck of actually just
trying to create things and I really
struggled and those were the worst days
of my life
um it led to some of the best days uh
but just the worst days emotionally
feeling like I was worthless
and so that's why I do what I do
because I want to help all the 19 year
old Evans out there not struggle as much
as I struggle not be as embarrassed to
ask for help not to be as ashamed to
feel like a total failure not to feel
like I'm going through this alone not to
have zero mentors and building this up
not to pretend like everything is great
when it's not
and it's not only talking to 19 year
olds around the world you know it could
be you it could be a 52 year old woman
and it was going through the same thing
it's that emotion and so I love helping
I love helping I've helped a lot of big
people with their channels and their
businesses but uh my heart is really in
the startup because that's where I
really struggled the most myself
and so that's what I'm trying to create
an everyday wake up and and try to do
something else whether it's a YouTube
video or a tick tock or an Instagram or
write the book or speaking engagement
and whatever the next thing is VR Evan
and hologram Evan and 3D Evan and
whatever beaming into your living room
this is something forever
when people ask me how do you how have
you not burnt out how have you how do
you keep going
so many years later thousands of videos
later
well I I feel like I'm living my purpose
it's another I record videos on Tuesday
it's another Tuesday sitting here in the
car and my wife is at her acupuncture
appointment and I'm I joined her and I'm
I've got my coffee and I'm sitting in
the car making videos and this is video
number I don't know how many thousand
and why keep going well because I feel
like this video will mean something to
at least one person
maybe it hits a million people maybe it
hits one person but it's going to be
valuable to at least one person and when
you can feel that when you can genuinely
feel that that you're making something
that's gonna actually touch at least one
human being
that's a good that's a good addiction to
get you know I feel like we matter so
think back to what was the most painful
moment of your life
you want to find your vision you want to
find your purpose what's the most
painful moment of your life when did you
struggle the most as a human when did
you feel the most worthless useless it
doesn't mean that you were suicidal
though maybe you were but it also
doesn't mean that you're in depression
you know maybe you were but when did you
just feel the lowest I never had any
Suicidal Thoughts I don't think I was
depressed either but I felt really low
when was that moment for you what were
the worst days of your life and your
purpose is then to help other people who
are struggling with that very same thing
because you've made it through
and it it doesn't mean that you're done
growing and learning I'm I'm still
learning I'm still growing that's why I
still watch videos and make videos
because I'm I'm still learning and
that's great you want to climb you climb
forever you never want to stop
progressing and stop climbing that's the
whole idea you know beyond the mountain
there's more Mountains you want to you
want to climb forever swim forever play
the game forever there is no Finish Line
that's the best part of it and every
time you take another step you reach
back and you help somebody get to where
you're at
and so you've learned a lot of lessons
if you think about who you used to be go
back to that moment where you were
struggling the most and that person you
know for me it's probably sitting at my
business partner's dining room table
just frustrated
lost
tried everything nothing's working how
am I here why did I say no to that job
why did I say yes to this what did I
just throw away everything my whole life
you know it'd be overly dramatic but
that's what was going through my mind
this is what I was actually thinking so
I had it had you know what could I what
would I go back and tell that Evan
so for you what was the most painful
moment in your life imagine a picture it
see yourself there who are you with
where are you you know what's the
setting around you and imagine you can
go back and talk to that person younger
you you had 15 minutes with that person
what would you say
you could help that person
you don't have to be Simon sinek or Tony
Robbins or Oprah Winfrey whoever you can
go back and help younger you
can give them some advice and in fact
younger you would probably listen to you
a lot more than they would listen to me
or Simon Samick or Tony Robbins Oprah
Winfrey or whoever because you've gone
through it they know who you are they
know that you understand them and so
they need your help
and that's that's what you create
whether it's making YouTube videos
whether it's some product or service
that you end up selling whether it's
joining some other organization who has
a similar Vision that you're gonna tie
yourself to
but that's what you want to do that will
make your life meaningful that will make
you feel valuable that'll make you feel
connected to the thing that you're
waking up every day doing I think
ultimately that's what makes people
happy
and so your vision comes from your
purpose your purpose comes from your
pain
and if you felt like you're reaching
back and touching younger you and
helping make sure that other people
don't have to struggle and suffer as
much as you did
that's the secret
that's the answer that's the path to
fulfillness happiness money and most
importantly
feeling like you are proud of yourself
and that you matter also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three leave your
comfort zone every day there's a battle
raging inside you the battle is between
the Comfort version of yourself and the
growth version of yourself the comfort
you
wants to be comfortable doesn't want to
push wants to stay where you are it's
it's difficult it's scary out there
let's stay warm and comfortable and the
growth version of you
wants to grow wants to learn wants to
develop wants to progress wants to serve
wants to help and doing that requires
have encouraged boldness and jumping
into the unknown and it's a daily battle
it's a daily battle that never goes away
and you have to choose who consistently
is going to win and those daily battles
are not won by doing the big heroic once
a year things it's one by doing the
daily things the daily small things that
shift your identity forward to teach
yourself that your the growth kind of
person and not the Comfort kind of
person
the first time I met Brendan burchard
was at his event at growth.com I was
speaking in Phoenix it was his event I
was one of two guest speakers it was him
and his partner speaking and then me and
Eric Thomas and his business partner
invited me to come and speak
and it flew me down there and I'd never
met Brendan before I knew I knew of him
obviously uh but I didn't never met him
face to face and when I when I met him
he came backstage uh I think it was the
day before I was gonna go speak and I
met him backstage and he said hey I
can't I can't wait to to see you on
stage uh I almost never bring on guest
speakers who I haven't seen speak before
but you came highly recommended by my
business partner so let's do this and
I'm gonna watch your speech and
see what you do I have a TV interview
that I'm doing and I'm going to pause
that and make sure I'm done so I can
watch your speech so in my head there's
a lot of stress and pressure one I never
met Brendan before two there's a couple
thousand people out there in the
audience uh and three usually when
speakers are on stage the other speakers
aren't super paying attention you know
they're backstage in their own world
doing their own thing but Brendan was
gonna end his interview to make sure
that he was going to watch my speech and
so he was adding all this extra pressure
on me this is the Battle of of growth
versus comfort of growth Evan versus
Comfort Evan my biggest fear of
disappointing people I don't want to
disappoint him I don't want to
disappoint the person who paid me to be
there I don't want to disappoint the
couple thousand people in the audience
and so we go through these moments
where the comfort you takes over the
comfort you wants to play small wants to
quit wants it back down wants to find
and out wants to find an excuse for why
you can't do something and the growth
you is struggling for control
there's two things that I do that help
growth Evan come out and I want you to
internalize them to apply them to use
them because if you can use these two
strategies it can massively shift your
identity forward help you become the
growth version of you instead of the
Comfort version of you and start giving
you the results you want as well as a
more purposeful happy life of service
two things first one
take on the identity that you do
difficult things
you do difficult things that if
something is scary or difficult or hard
that it's not a good enough reason that
you do scary you do difficult you love
hard
and so I use those as triggers and why
it's important is you shortcut the
thinking pattern every time that you say
that it's scary there's difficult that
it's hard or whatever words that you use
that give yourself a break that let
yourself off the hook use those as
trigger words the fact that you set it
means you have to do it
the fact that you said it you thought it
you wrote it means you have to do it
just because
what it does is it shortcuts the excuse
because what normally happens is you say
well that's that's too difficult you've
accepted that difficult is a good enough
reason for you to play small you don't
go and do the thing
you've accepted any excuses that come
into your head over why you can't do it
they're not you don't call them excuses
you call them you call them reasons
right logical valid reasons why you
can't do it
I want to shortcut all that I don't want
to even allow you to go there because I
don't allow myself to go there the fact
that I said scary difficult Hearts mean
I have to do it
so find your trigger words you can use
mine as a starting point if you want but
find your trigger words
and that becomes your new identity
you want to take on the identity that
you do difficult things
that you you jump into the unknown that
those are no longer good enough reasons
for you and so I did this when I was
backstage when I'm my heart's beating uh
I'm I'm I forgot what I was gonna say
going on stage like in the moments
leading up to going on stage I forgot
what I was gonna say I have no slides
either on stage right I don't go with a
PowerPoint presentation there's one
slide that just has my my name and face
on it that's it no slides as if I forget
what I'm gonna say God I'm screwed
so breathe
I Evan Carmichael does difficult things
I do difficult things right you remind
yourself what that does is put you into
a more resourceful state to go and
actually solve the problem
so that's step one you do difficult
things and and again it's not just the
big hero moments it's the micro there's
difficult things that have happened
already today that you have not done
what you need to do
because it was difficult and you give
yourself an out go do it
what that does for your self-love for
your self-pride for your self-respect
for your self-confidence is incredible
and and you need to give yourself that
gift I want you to give yourself that
gift every day of doing a difficult
thing and for you something that's
difficult may seem trivial or small for
somebody else when I broke my neck and
and was struggling with a concussion
getting out of bed
was difficult
just getting out of bed and putting my
feet on the ground and standing up was
incredible pain through my spine
incredible pain which is something I
take for granted now but that was
difficult
and so when when those things happen you
pat yourself on the back you did it you
did the difficult thing so that's step
number one you do difficult things
the second mindset shift is leaning into
service
it's not even about you newsflash it's
not about you
you're here to serve you're here to help
you're you're for all the Ambitions that
you have for yourself whatever the thing
is that you're afraid to do usually the
thing we're afraid to do is in front of
somebody else you're not afraid of
failing you're afraid of failing and
who's going to see you fail
right you will sing in the shower but
you won't sing on the street corner why
people will film videos at in home at
their home but not film it on the street
where people can see them because you're
afraid of being watched
you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people
you need to stop being selfish
get out of your own head and recognize
that you're here to serve you're here to
help you've got a message knowledge
information that can help people and by
you playing small you're doing a
disservice to them and to yourself
and so that's the other thing that I'll
lean into is yeah Evan Carmichael does
difficult things but also I'm here to
serve and so when I'm backstage and I'm
I know Brendan's going to watch me and I
know thousands of people are watching me
and afraid of disappointing everybody I
look out into the audience and instead
of seeing 2 000 people who are here to
judge me and I'm going to disappoint
them
I'm here looking at them saying I have a
message that can help them
I'm here to serve them because what I'm
going to share
Brendan doesn't know
Eric Thomas doesn't know the other
speakers here his Partners they don't
know I can share something unique that
can help them and my my intention is
good I'm here to help these people not
rip them off not leave them down a dark
path I'm here to help them and that
again shifts how you feel about yourself
to give you the Courage the boldness the
motivation the power to go and then do
the thing that the growth version of you
needs that's how you get out of the
comfort zone that's how you get out of
comfort you scared you small you into
powerful you bold you courageous you
growth you
number one you do difficult things
anytime you find yourself complaining
scary difficult hard negative you do
difficult things and number two you're
here to serve
you're here to serve you're here to help
you're trying to do good and keeping
your gifts to yourself is selfish and
you have to share it and get it out
there those two things on a daily basis
on a daily basis every single day that's
that battle raging inside your head
between the growth you and the comfort
you and my ambition my intention my goal
for you
is to have growth you win a little bit
more than comfort you it's not going to
be 100 growth to you there's no way
that's going to happen don't make that
Perfection the bar it's that every day
growth you wins at least 51 of the
battles versus comfort you you do that
your life will change
number four
shift in perspective on one of your
beliefs your habits your routines the
results that you're getting all come
from what you believe to be true about
your life and the world and for you to
get different results than you're
getting right now in your life you're
going to have to change your perspective
on one or more of your beliefs so this
topics makes me think about my favorite
comment of all time if you think about
my YouTube channel I've had it for 11
years and I don't know how many
thousands of thousands of comments my
favorite comment of all time was we
profiled a black entrepreneur and one of
the guys in the comments said growing up
my parents taught me that black people
were the n-word and you just changed my
perspective today I was willing to learn
from a black man
and
it blew my mind because when I first set
out to make my channel uh it wasn't
really about race or willingness to
learn from other people it was it was
more hey these people have accomplished
success you should go and learn from
them I wasn't set out to try to solve
sexism or racism or anything uh so big
like that
but what had happened was I had enough
credibility with this person and I
didn't know them from anything they just
watched enough of my videos but then
when I made this video on a black man he
decided you know what I'm gonna give it
a few minutes and that experience
changed his perspective that then will
hopefully go off and change his life
imagine having that belief that then
changes what kind of ripple effect that
has on the rest of your life and that's
what happens when you get exposed to New
Opportunities and new people New
Perspectives you you were raised with a
perspective
your parents your family community a
super isolated perspective that you feel
is right and many of those things may
still be right for who you want to
become but if you want to have greater
success greater levels of confidence
greater levels of happiness and purpose
and fulfillment than the people around
you you're gonna have to believe
something that's different than what
they believe you're going to have to
surround yourself with other people
who've actually gone off and done that
thing because the people around you
aren't giving you the thing that you
need and so that's one of my main goals
with this channel I know people come in
to learn from people who are like them
you learn from people who who look like
you who might be the same sex or same
gender in the same industry or use the
same language as you
but what I'm really hoping to do as well
is in that process you came for this one
person you came for this one thought or
one idea and I want to expose you to a
whole bunch of different perspectives
all still within the lens of belief
right everything on my channels all of
the channels are always positive it's
always believed it's always optimistic
it's always uplifting but I want to try
to hit you with different perspectives
and angles because Eric Thomas and Jaco
willink are gonna yell at you through
something and Oprah Winfrey and Wayne
Dyer are gonna hug you through something
and sometimes maybe you need to yell and
sometimes you need the hug but I want to
give you different perspectives to help
you become the best version of you okay
so how do I make the perspective shifts
that we need to make in our life to get
to the spot that we want to be I've got
a three-step process let's go step
number one is learn to learn from people
that you hate
this is one of the most important things
that I can that I can articulate that I
can push you towards find somebody who's
had success
ideally in some kind of related field
but still has some success that you hate
for some reason
and force yourself to learn from them
force yourself to find one thing about
them that you can learn to make you
better at what to do so even looking at
my wall here right I like to tell the
story I've got I've got Steve Jobs here
and I got my dad here I want to be a
Visionary like Steve Jobs and a father
like my father I don't want to be a
father like Steve Jobs as a Visionary
like my dad right the whole point of
this is for you to be the best you and
for that to happen you pull different
things from different people
you may Hate Everything About Steve Jobs
or everything about Kanye West at the
back wall there but there's but there's
one thing there's one thing that you can
learn from that person to help you be
better that's often a thing that unlocks
a huge chunk of learning
people typically lock themselves in a
box you've trapped yourself in a box of
learning of saying I'm only going to
learn from these kinds of people and so
you get the same kind of messages over
and over and over again but really if
you want to unlock your learning
finding people who you disagree with who
you may hate you may hate a lot about
them but examining how they've had
success a good starting point is the top
tens on my other channel right it's
always positive it's something that I've
learned from if I can learn from them
you could probably learn from them as
well there's one little nugget out of
those 10 rules maybe that can apply to
your life and when I was learning from
Kanye West Kanye West was somebody who's
to bother me a lot I saw somebody who's
got a giant ego somebody who who I I
didn't want to be like but I realized
you know what I can learn from this guy
I can learn from this guy I can learn to
think bigger like Kanye I can learn to
be a better friend if you know the story
of him and John Legend I can learn to be
a better friend like Kanye that you
can't really see that picture there but
he's on a radio interview and and he's
saying In that clip uh the time is now
to be the greatest you I don't want to
sit inside a corporation for the next 30
Years like this is the time the time is
now let's go I believe that I need to
remember that even more like the time is
now not tomorrow not in three years not
next month like it's right now the time
is now free you can learn that from
Kanye right now even if you hate him so
step number one is find somebody who you
hate go to my top 10 Channel or my main
Channel and go back in the archives and
find somebody who you see their picture
and it drives you nuts already great
force yourself to go learn one thing
from that person that's the starting
point for shifting your perspective step
number two is say it's the best it's the
best this is one of the most valuable
perspective shifts that I think any
human can make is when you're faced with
something that's negative something that
that most people will complain of and
the old you used to complain about you
shifted and say this is the best this is
the best this thing has happened to me
right now this is the best this
coronavirus is happening right now for
me it's the best shift your perspective
to say this is the best because what it
does is it moves you from a place of
being complaining and upset and angry
and unproductive into a place of
possibility of resourcefulness of you
now showing to yourself and to the world
what you're capable of and so when I
broke my neck when there's a fire alarm
going off when we have Corona this is
this is how I stay productive this is
how I stay focused this is how I stay
pushing forward when most people are
complaining and negative is I tell
myself this is the best
this is my chance this is an opportunity
and I think this is this is the one of
the biggest things that entrepreneurs
who've had the biggest success Crush at
so many entrepreneurs have built their
businesses the ones that you look up to
and respect and admire and want to be
like they built their businesses in the
toughest times they build their
businesses in recessions and depressions
why because they said it's the best so
whatever that thing is it feels
overwhelming all all-encompassing
negative in your life stop complaining
about it and say this is the best I'm
growing I'm getting stronger through
this adversity I'm going to make
something amazing as a result of it and
step number three is the first time yes
rule the first time yes rule is the
first time you get invited to something
or an idea comes your head say yes
most people are in the no business most
people are looking at all the reasons
why it's not going to work and you can't
do this and you have no skills or
abilities or time or resources you're
always finding those we're in the no
business of what we can't do stuff we've
told ourselves we can't do these things
just say yes the first time
this is one of the things I love most
about my wife Nina is all come with all
sorts of crazy ideas and the first time
she'll say yes
we'll see right you want to drive to to
Boston with with two videographers in
the back and film yes perfect you want
to go to satguru in Philadelphia and
spend two days meditate yes perfect you
will even though you hate the cold you
wanna sit in an ice bath with Wim Hof
when it comes to Toronto and fill me yes
perfect doesn't mean she's gonna do it
again she hasn't sat in a nice bath
since but it's the first time yes the
first time yes rule is one of the
biggest mentality shifts that if you can
make you'll open yourself up to so many
more opportunities I look at dancing for
example trying to dance salsa right the
other another business that I run and
operate the number of people who come in
and are scared and super nervous and
it's their first time dancing ever as an
adult and then you see the shift that
they make in the identity of like I just
did that
I danced I never thought I could dance
and here I got a few basic steps of a
move and if they keep coming back
they'll keep getting better
a lot of times you're not making the
perspective shift that you need because
you're not trying enough new stuff
because you're in the no business first
time yes rule you get an idea somebody
asks you for something somebody wants to
try something with you yes first time
yes doesn't mean you keep doing it and
as long as it doesn't go against your
ethics or your values that don't go rob
a bank because they said first time yes
okay we're not talking about that kind
of stuff
but when you feel a little bit outside
your comfort zone is like I'm not the
kind of person who does that
first time yes rule just see you might
surprise yourself and rule number five
the last one before our very special
bonus clip trigger yourself for
successes the trick to getting yourself
into action mode is to trigger yourself
for Success triggering yourself for
Success means you've taken the decision
making out of it that as soon as you
come up with an idea you have trained
Yourself by default into action mode you
see your brain will always talk you down
from things because it's trying to keep
you safe and it only understands a world
that currently exists that is logical
and practical until you learn to trigger
yourself for Success you will constantly
doubt your thoughts your ideas and your
actions this video is gonna help so
today I want to talk about this bag
right here a lot of you leave comments
of newer fans of the channel say why is
Doritos sponsoring your videos Evan why
don't you have a healthier sponsor don't
you know what bad Doritos does to your
body you should be promoting healthy
living
sponsor guys this is this is triggering
me for Success every single day and this
isn't just some tiny bag it looks small
looking back here but let me bring this
up look at that this is right next to my
face look at how big that baggage
readers is
I have a strategy and it's a weird
strategy so maybe you'll love it maybe
you won't but I have a strategy called
Damn the Doritos I look at this bag so
I'm sitting this is how I'm working
right I'm not sitting I'm standing I'm
standing on a trampoline this is my
workspace right now right I'm standing
here I'm working in the corner of my eye
I got Steve Jobs up here and I got I got
this giant bag of Doritos all I want to
do is eat this bag all day long I want
to destroy this bag of Doritos
look at that giant chip oh
I'm gonna start drooling soon I love it
I want to eat that all day long
this bag is here as a reminder of how
great I am this is the mental
conversation inside my head Evan you're
awesome you're awesome for not eating
those Doritos every day and I want it as
a reminder people say it doesn't take a
lot of willpower
no it it builds for me at least builds
the willpower builds my strength every
time I see that bag of Doritos makes me
feel better about myself that I'm not
eating it and I have the strength to
keep going and so why I have that here
is when you're on a diet right this is
how it began when you're on a diet your
friends your family the experts will say
get rid of all the junk food from your
house get rid of it all because
otherwise you'll be tempted and then
you're gonna eat it and then you're
gonna ruin your diet I think that is
actually teaching yourself that you suck
you're teaching yourself I'm a weird
duck you're teaching yourself that you
are not strong enough to be around the
thing and so I need to get it out of my
environment the only way that I can
stick to this thing is if this other
stuff is nowhere close to me I think
you're telling yourself that you suck I
think it's a big crutch and just like
when you break your leg you have a
crutch your ultimate goal is to not have
a crutches to walk it's to run is to be
stronger than before right and so as a
step one maybe it's good right it's a
step one okay fine you broke your leg
you have a crutch you want to get on a
diet you're addicted to junk food get
out of the house awesome but as soon as
you go on vacation as soon as you go to
an office party as soon as you go to the
New Year's any kind of party you're
gonna destroy the food because you've
trained yourself every day that you suck
that you're not capable I think you're a
genius I think you're stronger than you
think and so I tested it first with
myself and I thought you know what
Doritos are my Nemesis right I love
Doritos
oh my gosh she's looking at that bag so
I went to Costco and bought the giant
sized bag of Doritos I said I'm going to
put this on my desk all day long because
damn the Doritos because the Doritos are
stronger than me I don't think so right
I'm Evan Carmichael and same thing for
you
that thing that is holding you that's
that's stronger than you I don't think
so remember who you are remember how
strong you are and that's what this is
here for and it's been awesome to see
people now take this up a friend of the
channel uh LeRon was trying to get off
of sugar and he has a coffee cup with a
saucer and he drinks his morning coffee
and he put two packets of sugar on the
saucer right next to the coffee so he
pourses coffee has the sugar right next
to it and he just starts drinking it and
puts it down and looks at the sugar
packs and then just drinks the coffee
again and puts it down looks at the
sugar pack and his wife thinks he's
crazy and he's a little crazy too you
got to be a little bit weird duck but
but I think this is actually how you
build your strength
Mark Drake another friend of the channel
is addicted to the peak friends cookies
you know the ones that have the the red
on the inside and the cream in the
middle those are among my favorites too
and so his CEO when he heard this went
out and bought all these boxes of peak
frames and put it on Mark's desk and he
opened it up and this is one of my
favorite things to do when whenever I'm
around Doritos or something I really
love to to eat not just say oh put that
away from me don't be around me I can't
have that and not just look at it I want
to smell it
so Mark took these cookies brought it
right up here Peak free cookies right up
here
oh and you can just see the Joy on his
face Jess as he's bringing back memories
and just what those cookies are gonna
taste like when they enter his stomach
and just um goodness everywhere right
the smile on his face maybe a little bit
of drool coming out he just oh
and then put the cookies down and walk
away
and how great that makes you feel as a
human to say here's one of my biggest
weaknesses of all time Bring It
I own you put it down and walk away
right I think that's how you actually
build strength by doing those difficult
things by triggering yourself for
Success every time I see the Doritos bag
I feel better about myself I feel
stronger about myself and I want you to
do the same thing if any of you are
gonna take on that kind of challenge I
want to hear you I want to follow you I
want to I want to see how your journey
is going because it can be one of the
biggest most important life-changing
decisions that you embark on
lack of consistency is one of the
biggest reasons why entrepreneurs fail
one of the biggest reasons you're a
genius you have great ideas you want to
serve you know you're capable of more
and you have these moments of
inspiration and moments of boldness and
moments of massive productivity and
focus and Clarity but it's not
consistent and that's why most
entrepreneurs will lose
because you might crush it on a Saturday
or Sunday or Monday but then Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday you fall back
down until the next Saturday when you're
up and flying again it's not enough it's
much more about what you do every day
you are what you consistently do it's a
huge problem for entrepreneurs so let's
fix them number one if you are a
part-time entrepreneur if you work for
someone else your part-time entrepreneur
you need to make sure that every single
day you're working on your business
every single day you have to work on
your business no matter what even if
it's for 15 minutes at night every
single day you cannot let momentum die
even just to show yourself that you can
even if it's a crazy long day and your
boss is yelling at you and you come home
and your spouse is angry and your kids
are sick even then you have to spend 15
minutes on your business half an hour in
your business every single day you
cannot let the momentum die don't
disappoint yourself number two if you're
already full-time in your business great
you need to have CEO time every day in
your business see CEO time time where
you spend being the CEO what does that
mean it's different for different
entrepreneurs but when you're working on
the business instead of in it if you
spend all time just working in the
business just putting out fires and
never growing guess what you're never
going to grow if you never have CEO time
built into your business you will never
be a CEO and so you need to make sure
that every day you have CEO time built
into your business again maybe it's only
half an hour but in that half an hour
you're spending time growing your
company you're going to start seeing
results and my last tip is I want you to
start your morning off powerfully I want
you to chart your start I want you to
have a morning routine that inspires you
that makes you feel bold most people
what do they do when they wake up first
thing they do is they hit the snooze
button what does that mean it means last
night you set a goal I'm going to wake
up at a certain time right I'm gonna
wake up at 6 a.m 5 a.m 7 A.M 12 noon I
don't care what time you have to wake up
you set a goal you're gonna wake up and
then the very first thing that you do
how you start your day every day is just
say I am not going to hit my ball today
that's how you start your day that's how
most of America starts your day they say
I'm not going to hit my goal today how
do you think you're going to go off and
have an amazing day and crush it and go
hit your crazy big goals and Ambitions
that you have as an entrepreneur when
you tell yourself and you reinforce it
every morning that you are the kind of
person who doesn't hit their goals you
got to change that you gotta wake up
wake up when you say You're Gonna wake
up get out of bed when you say you're
gonna get out of bed
that's step one then step two is what is
a morning routine that sets you up for
Success most people wake up like it's an
accident wake up you check your phone
you're responding to other people's
emergencies and their agenda for your
time
that's not how you need to start your
day successful people they own their
morning what does your morning look like
and we've all felt inspired involved at
some point you felt it you've been bold
you've been inspired at some point in
your life great whatever that thing was
it made you feel bold Unstoppable
inspired put that into your morning
routine maybe just watching video maybe
it's reading the book maybe it's doing
an act of kindness maybe it's meditating
maybe it's prayer whatever it is with
intention because some of you have a
morning routine already I'm talking to
you you have a morning routine already
but you're not crushing it every day
you're not coming out of that morning
routine stealing bold inspired
consistently that's what we're talking
about consistency here sometimes you
just go through the motions of your
morning routine sometimes you just pray
but you're not really connecting
sometimes you just watch a video but
you're making your breakfast you're
brushing your teeth and you're not
paying attention with intention do your
morning routine you must come out of
your morning routine every single day
feeling bold Unstoppable and confident
if you did that if you woke up every day
on time like you say you're going to
you're not gonna hit the snooze button
you get out of bed and then you did the
thing that made you feel bold powerful
and Unstoppable every single day holy
cow I guarantee you your life one year
from today will look dramatically
different than where you are right now
consistency is the game you are what you
consistently do and I want to see you
win
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort